There are some interesting
challenges in threshold learning in the
filtering problem.
So here I show the historical data that
you can collect in a filtering system
so you can see the scores and the
status of relevance.
So the first one it has a score of 36.5
and it's relevant.
The second one is non-relevant and etc.
Of course we have a lot of documents
for which we don't know the status
because we have never delivered them to
the user.
So as you can see here, we only see the
judgments of documents delivered to the
user, so this is not a random sample,
so it's censored data.
It's kind of biased.
So that creates some difficulty for
learning, and secondly there are in
general very little labeled data,
and very few relevant data, so
it's also challenging for machine
learning approaches.
Typically they require more
training data, and in the extreme case
at the beginning we don't even have any
label data as well.
The system still has to make a
decision, so that's a very difficult
problem at the beginning.
Finally, there is also this issue of
exploration versus exploitation
tradeoff.
Now this means we also want to explore
the document space a little bit
and to see if the user might be interested
in documents that we haven't delivered.
So in other words, we're going to
explore the space of user interests by
testing whether the user might be
interested in some other documents that
currently are not matching the users'
interests so well.
So how do we do that?
Well, we could lower the threshold a
little bit and do just deliver some
near misses to the user to see what the
user would respond,
to see how the user would respond
to this extra document.
And this is the trade-off because on the
one hand you want to explore, but on
the other hand you don't want to really
explore too much 'cause then you would
overdeliver non-relevant information.
So exploitation means you would exploit
what you learned about user.
Let's say you know the user is interested in
this particular topic so you don't want
to deviate that much.
But if you don't deviate at all then
you don't explore it all.
That's also not good.
You might miss opportunity to learn another
interest of the user.
So this is a dilemma.
And that's also a difficult problem to
solve.
Now how do we solve these problems?
In general,
I think one can use the empirical
utility optimization strategy, and this
strategy is basically to optimize the
threshold based on historical data,
just as you have seen on the previous
slide.
So you can just compute the utility on
the training data for each candidate
score threshold.
Pretend what if I cut at this point.
What if I can cut at a different
scoring threshold point what would
happen, what's utility?
Since these are training data, we can
kind of compute the utility, right?
We know their relevance status or we
assume that we know relevant status
that's based on approximation of
clickthroughs.
So then we can just choose the
threshold that gives the maximum
utility on the training data.
But this of course doesn't account for
exploration that we just talked about.
And there is also the difficulty of
bias training sample as we mentioned.
So in general we can only get upper
bound for the true optimal
threshold, because the threshold might
be actually lower than this.
So it's possible that the discarded
item might be actually interesting to
the user.
So how do we solve this problem where
we generate and
as I said, we can lower the threshold
to explore a little bit, so here's one
particular approach called better
gamma threshold learning.
So the idea is following.
So here I show a ranked list of all the
training documents that we have seen so
far, and they are ranked by their
positions. And on the y-axis,
We show the utility.
Of course this function depends on how
you specify the coefficients in the
utility function, but we can then
imagine.
that depending on the cut off position, we
will have a utility that means.
Suppose I cut at this position and that
would be the utility.
So we can, for example identify some
cutting cut off point.
The optimal point theta optimal is
the point when we would achieve the
maximum utility if we had chosen this
threshold.
And there is also zero threshold zero
utility threshold, and you can see at
this cut off the utility is 0. Now what
does that mean?
That means if I lower the threshold a
little bit and now I reach this
threshold, the utility would be lower,
but it's still positive it's still non
negative at least.
So it's not as high as the optimal
utility.
But it gives us a safe point to explore
the threshold.
As I just explained, it's desirable to
explore the interest space, so it's
desirable to lower the threshold based
on your training data.
So that means in general we want to set
the threshold somewhere in this range.
Let's say we can use alpha to control
the deviation from
the optimal utility
point so you can see the formula of the
threshold would be just the
interpolation of the zero utility
threshold and the optimal utility
threshold.
Now the question is how should we set
alpha?
And when should we deviate more from the
optimal utility point?
Well this can depend on multiple factors and
one way to solve the problem is to
encourage this
threshold mechanism to explore up to
the zero point, and that's a safe
point, but we're not going to
necessarily reach all the way to the
zero point, but rather we're going to
use other parameters to further define
alpha, and this specifically is as
follows.
So there will be a beta parameter to
control the deviation from the optimal
threshold, and this can be based on
for example can be accounting for the
overfitting to the training data let's say.
And so this can be just
adjustment factor.
But what's more interesting is this
gamma parameter here and you can see in
this formula,
gamma is controlling the
influence of the number of examples in
training dataset.
So you can see it in this formula as
N which denotes the number of
training examples becomes bigger, then
it would actually encourage less
exploration.
In other words, when N is very small,
it would try to explore more, and that
just means if we have seen few examples
we're not sure whether we have exhausted
the space of interests.
So we would explore.
But as we have seen many examples from
the user, many data points, then we
feel that we probably don't have to
explore more.
So this gives us a dynamic strategy for
exploration, right?
The more examples we have seen, the
less explosion we're going to do, so
the threshold would be closer to the
optimal threshold.
So that's the basic idea of this
approach.
Now this approach, it actually has been
working well in some evaluation studies
empirically effective.
And also can work on arbitrary utility
with a proper lower bound.
And it explicitly addresses the exploration-
exploitation tradeoff and it kind of uses
the zero utility threshold point as a
safeguard for exploration and
exploitation tradeoff, we are never
going to explore further than the zero
utility point.
So if you take the analogy of gambling
and you don't want to risk on
losing money, so it's a safe strategy.
The conservative strategy for
exploration.
And the problem is, of course this
approach is purely heuristic.
And the zero utility lower bound is
also often too conservative.
And there are of course more advanced
machine learning approaches that have
been proposed for solving these
problems, and this is the active
research area.
So to summarize, there are two
strategies for recommender systems or
filtering systems.
One is content based which is looking
at the item similarity.
The other is collaborative filtering,
which is looking at the user
similarity.
In this lecture, we've covered the
content based filtering approach in the
next lecture we're going to talk about
collaborative filtering.
In content-based filtering system,
We generally have to solve several
problems related to filtering decision
and learning etc.
And such a system can actually be
built based on a search engine system
by adding a threshold mechanism, and
adding adaptive learning algorithm to
allow the system to learn from
long-term feedback from the user.